[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Hello there.
Welcome back to another episode.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And
hello from me, Priyanka.
HEATHER CROSS: Today, we'll
introduce Google Cloud Pub/Sub,
a messaging service that
allows you to send and receive
messages between
independent applications.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
We'll also run
through a quick demo
of the self-paced lab
where we will explore various
publishing and subscribing
activities.
HEATHER CROSS: And
you want to know more
on how to test this with your
own application after the lab?
Well, check out our
free trial credit
to get started on
Google Cloud Platform.
Let's first answer what
Pub/Sub means as a service.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
So a published
subscribed service
is a messaging service where
the senders of messages, called
publishers, are decoupled
from receivers of messages,
called subscribers.
HEATHER CROSS: The
published messages
are categorized into topics.
Subscribers who have
expressed interest in a topic
will either pull
related messages
or choose to get push
messages from the topic.
Key to the service
is that neither party
is required to have any
knowledge of the other.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Cloud Pub/Sub is
great for distributing
event notifications.
Take an example of a service
that accepts user sign-ups.
It can send notifications
whenever a new user registers,
and downstream
services can subscribe
to receive notifications
of that event.
There are even examples
closer to home.
You know that smart home
technology you're so fond of?
HEATHER CROSS: Yes, I
do love my Google Home.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
the Pub/Sub service
is a part of the
architecture that
supports the streaming of
data from residential sensors
to the backend servers
that are hosted on cloud.
HEATHER CROSS: The
ability of Cloud Pub/Sub
to ingest millions of
streaming events per second
from anywhere in the world also
allows you to respond to events
as they happen.
Cloud Pub/Sub forms part
of Cloud's Stream Analytics
solution, which provides a
number of useful applications
such as performing
sentiment analysis,
identifying general
patterns and trends in data,
monitoring the performance
and reach of campaigns,
and crafting messages
in real time.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Time
again for Qwik labs.
The Cloud Pub/Sub lab
is available for use
with GCloud command line tool,
as well as through the Google
Cloud Platform console.
You can check out the link
to start Qwik labs here.
And for a limited time, you
can try these labs for free.
HEATHER CROSS: Each of the
labs cover the activities
of setting up a topic to hold
data, subscribing to a topic
to access the data, and then
publishing and consuming
messages with a pull subscriber.
The lab will take about
30 minutes to complete.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So far in the lab,
we've created a Pub/Sub topic
using the Google Cloud Platform
console and added
a subscription.
You can see the number
of subscriptions
listed for the topic is one.
You can use the
console to publish
a message to Pub/Sub topic.
In this case, we are publishing
the message "Hello Demo."
To view the message,
you use the subscription
to pull the message
from the topic.
Well, there we have it.
We hope you enjoyed
this episode and would
love to hear more about how you
use or would use Google Cloud
Pub/Sub.
HEATHER CROSS: And
don't forget, you
can apply what you've learned
today with a $300 free trial
credit to get started on
Google Cloud Platform.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: You can also
learn more about Cloud Pub/Sub
through a number of other
Google Cloud training resources.
All the links are listed below.
Thanks for watching,
and see you soon.
Want to know more about
Deployment Manager?
Check out last week's episode
where we dive into a lab
and highlight the service.